[Musique]
non
sur le plateau d' interdit d'interdire
je reçois bruno mouron et pascal rostain
dgde plus célèbre paparazzi devenue rude
au log
vous allez voir de quoi il s'agit en
prenant en photo les poubelles des stars
leurs images sont exposés et à vendre
dans 100 galeries yellow korner ce à
travers le monde jusqu'au 15 avril ainsi
qu'elle a une à saint germain des prés
je reçois également mahboula soumahoro
pour son livre le triangle et l'hexagone
et féloche pour son nouvel album avec le
mandoline orchestra leur tournée
s'arrêtera à paris aux trois baudets le
30 avril et on commence tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui la
caractérise voici la réponse de bruno
mouron en images voilà c'est un début
d'étude de poubelles voilà on ira plus
dans le détail après mais celle ci c'est
la poubelle de qui ça c'est la poubelle
d'un habitant d'un anonyme d'un quartier
très résidentiel à paris notamment à
neuilly un hôtel particulier la mise et
famille très aisée
donc on ne les reconnaît des produits de
luxe une consommation un peu soft de là
ce sont des poubelles que vous faites
sans que les gens sachent que
voulez-vous loire avait volé le bien sûr
à ce qu'on essaie de faire les
traitements
voilà sinon il a d'église qui ont
continué d'être des paparazzis vous
fouiller dans les poubelles et et voilà
ce que vous en sortez ça c'est une
famille aisée
ça c'est une famille aisée et on va voir
une famille pauvre
juste à côté alors leur voix un peu la
différence de produits ouais plus tôt il
ya l'idole sans menaçant les titres il
ya un peu ça c'est le village de
l'espace 2 de l'espoir de l'espoir
village de l'espoir à vitry ouais donc
ça c'est un peu différent pour il ya
beaucoup de produits évidemment
alimentaire de grande surface
et puis comme d'habitude la petite
bouteille rouge qu'on voit la canette de
coca cola à quai par de la boue des qui
est partout on va voir dans les photos
des leurs elle est absolument partout
voilà c'est juste un avant goût on y
revient dans quelques instants mahboula
soumahoro votre image à vous c'est el
haya nakamura voilà ayaka mimura jah jah
jah
elle est française elle est française et
faut-il le rappeler a les françaises
elle est aussi allée aussi banlieusards
d'années d'origine malienne elle a du
bagout elle est très critiquée elles
vont partout dans le monde
elle vend partout parce qu'elles
représenteraient linguistiquement la
perdition de la france alors que c'est
de l'artiste française je pense qu'
actuellement voir le plus à l'étranger
et c'est la nouvelle ambassadrice
il faut s'y faire bon on s'y fait très
bien pourquoi vous avez l'air de dire
qu'ils sont pleines oui en a qui s'en
plaignent
et justement la façon de parler la
culture aussi un peu comme entièrement
le hard largo quelques mots de langue
africaine où quelques monde de langue
caraïbes
ben voilà c'est moi je vais vous chanter
dans un défilé de mode pour la fashion
week tomberait produit exactement le
monde entier dans la fashion week est mû
par la fausse et j'adore cette petite et
nikos aliagas prononcent très bien son
nom exactement
donc voilà il ya des ja ja ja il ya des
moments comme ça on n'arrive pas à
prononcer son nom n'arriveront comprends
pas ce qu'elle est c'est à ya donc un
prénom malien nakamura japon il ya trop
de mélanger parfois on sait pas quoi en
faire
et moi j'adore j'adore cette petite
féloche on arrive à présent ses surnoms
mais ça veut rien dire donc si votre
allure et j'avoue ces peines quand
capuche yves rocher oui capucine tranché
c'est navigatrice et l'aller sur son
petit bateau qui s'appelle tara tari
c'est un bateau qui vient du bangladesh
qui est entièrement en fibre de jute et
cette photo de la trouve magnifique
donc il vient du bangladesh si je pense
t elle m'expliquait que c'était elle a
fait le traverser les océans la
méditerranée l'atlantique avec et dès
qu'elle arrive dans des tout seul comme
ça elle n'a pas de téléphone elle n'a
pas elle a juste elle récupère des trucs
elle a réussi à récupérer une fois un
panneau solaire
donc pour moi c'est un panneau voilà et
c'est une c'est comme une héroïne de
d'une série je suis pas comment on peut
imaginer un truc de de l'avenir c'est
l'avenir et c'est l'époque avec on voit
cette photo les trucs de récup et
l'essentiel en fait un gros carton
s'interdira de prendre l'avion
est-ce que ça la balance trop de co2 on
voyage raconte
mais surtout c'est ça l'idée
ce qu'elle dit c'est que elle peut pas
avoir grand chose avec elle donc à là
l'essentiel
et ça fait vraiment penser à l'époque ce
qu'il fallait trouver une photo de
l'époque un truc qui représente pour moi
même si elle est en avance c'est quand
même une photo voilà qui dit ça et puis
le bangladesh c'est le premier bateau du
bangladesh elle arrive c'est
complètement fou et elle est sur ce
bateau comme ça voilà
et ça m'a touché c'est j'écris une
chanson sur sur elle et son bateau
s'appelle tara tari et voilà et on est
devenus mêmes amis parce que parce
qu'elle reste un votre image à vous elle
va avoir l'air elle est très ancienne on
dirait là elle est très ancien mais pour
moi pour moi c'est un pont justement
parce qu'on demandait une photo de tir
présent de l'époque et moi c'était un
pont justement entre deux époques entre
le 20e et 21e siècle un personnage qui
nous en tant que photographe de presse
en tant que journaliste nous a vraiment
intéressés nous a passionné et puis il
est interdit d'interdire
lui non vie voilà il me dit tu le fais
tu le photographier en train de fumer
des clopes en train de boire des coups
c'est vraiment il représente tout ce que
nous n'avons plus le droit de montrer
aujourd'hui à la télévision plus le
droit de dire et d'ailleurs c'est drôle
parce que hier j'étais sur ma mobylette
en train de fumer un cigare est un flic
qui m'arrêtent qui me dit on faisait
paroisse de fumée il est interdit
d'interdire à une grenade je pensais pas
du tout à ton émission n'est pas du tout
je pense est un slogan plus ample
beaucoup plus anciens du siècle d'avant
et le mec qui m'a regardé il comprenait
pas ce qu'il était allé fumer sur sa sur
saab automobile est une apparente hui
mais enfin tu n'as plus le droit de rien
et chirac me fais justement penser au
dernier homme politique qui s'autorisent
est tout ouïe et c'est une période qu'on
a malheureusement qu'on a entraîné en
train de disparaître et bien commençons
[Musique]
bruno moreau et pascal rostain vous avez
été de très célèbre paparazzi est ce que
vous êtes encore lui absolument il est à
la face nord maintenant c'est un peu
plus difficile parce que le monde a
changé en dollars tous les appareils
photo / a complètement changé ce papa de
souama voilà donc maintenant c'est
complètement différent
et puis surtout les célébrités ne sont
plus du tout les mêmes nous on avait une
approche qui était complètement
différente et célébrités c'était presque
du copinage était à l'époque de la dolce
vita et plusieurs semaines que à la
maintenance et un peu hard 5 c'est un
peu dur notamment aux états unis
c'est très très dur où il ya vraiment de
la persécution il y avait la même chose
comme ça donc c'est un peu différent
et puis les célébrités sont plus du tout
les mêmes elles font elles ne font pas
ne font pas les mêmes folies
qu'auparavant et puis elles sont moins
célèbres on a la pression on a eu la
chance de commencer à une époque où les
gens qu'on photographier s'appelait
brigitte bardot grace kelly jacqueline
kennedy
richard burton lister leurs on parle un
peu paradoxal mais d'une élégance faute
des gens avec une élégance incroyable et
nous avions une attitude élégante en
face d'eux et on n'était pas cachée avec
des gros téléobjectif on était en phase
2 sur les trottoirs on était même
souvent bien habillés et c'était on
faisait partie de l'environnement des
célébrités et c'est vrai que dans les
années 70 à l'époque en plus le mot
n'était pas galvaudé c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ce mot est galvaudé mais
quand on a eu la chance d'être baptisé
parce que c'est federico fellini qui
nous a baptisé comme ça on peut en
accepter la paternité est en nette sans
en être fier c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
le mot paparazzi représente quelque
chose de totalement différent de la
période que nous avons connues lorsqu'on
a commencé à faire et on prenait on
parlait d'ailleurs nakamura
elle est célèbre pour une partie des
gens là plus il ya toute une partie des
gens qui ne sait pas qui elle est à
l'époque les célébrités étaient les
mêmes pour tout le monde
oui bien sûr mais maintenant il ya une
différence de com qui se font avec la
avec avec internet avec ses des médias
quiz différent de l'époque
ouais donc il est gentil segmenté voilà
le plus augmenté alors passons à votre
grande oeuvre
commencée il ya trente ans maintenant
tout début des années 90
alors est ce que parce que c'est parce
qu'on ne l'accusé de faire les poubelles
que vous avez eu l'idée de faire les
noms des stars
donc on va voir l'exposition aux toxines
qui a lieu donc dansant guéri comme
yellow korner à travers le monde et à la
librairie à la galerie la une à saint
germain des prés on va voir votre
première poubelle de stars c'est celle
de serge gainsbourg et ben voilà tout a
commencé en 88 avec serge et en fait ça
commençait pas ça va vous paraître
incroyable un article dans le monde d'un
prof de sociologie de montpellier qui
avait fait une étude sur la société de
consommation en france et pour ce faire
il a demandé à ses étudiants de
collecter les poubelles de dix familles
françaises pendant un an et il explique
dans son étude
c'est incroyable on voit ton adn parce
qu'on voit ce que tu manges que tu bois
si tu fumes ce que tu bookeen
si tu as des enfants si tu as des
animaux si je fais la poubelle de
frédéric taddeï sa soeur sandrine tout
le monde va le reconnaître
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
ton adn on voit bien voyez on reconnaît
les gitanes et gainsbourg à l'époque moi
je faisais toutes les photos de serge
donc je passais pas mal de temps avec
lui et en fait ils avaient ils n'avaient
jamais ses clés sur lui parce que bon
dans les vapeurs alcoolique des nuits
parisiennes et risquer de les perdre
et quand il rentrait chez lui c'était
fulbert son maître d'hôtel alors je sais
pas si le mec ça fait raymond marcel et
l'avait baptisé fulbert mais je crois
qu'ils avaient vraiment engagé parce
qu'ils s'appellent fulbert et fulbert
lui ouvrais la porte et un soir on
rentre et en ouvrant la porte il sort
les poubelles et là on a nos deux
neurones qui se font sonner tél il y en
a 10 à serge emprunter poubelle on a
piqué ses poubelles mais avec son accord
c'est le seul qui était au courant qu'on
ait pris ces poubelles
on l'a même pas ce qu'on allait faire
avec alors que tu m'as ils savaient plus
à cette heure là et on arrive au studio
léon létale comme ça de façon très
taxidermiste sur un fond de velours noir
c'est ça qui est très beau tour leur oui
c'est paradoxal a lancé aux
accumulations darnand marmande et
prairies
c'est pour ça que depuis ça a été
accroché dans tous les musées dans
toutes les grandes villes dans le monde
entier et le tour du monde des magazines
mais aussi des musées et c'était
tellement caricaturale des poubelles de
serge qu on a hésité à continuer on
s'est dit les gens vont penser qu'on
fait des trucs mais qu'on l'a imaginé et
d'ailleurs il ya un truc qu'on n'a
jamais lui faudrait qu'on le lise
c'est là c'est un scénario qu'il a écrit
que personne ne connaît ça s'appelle
maison est close maison est close et je
sais pas du tout de quoi ça parle alors
il ya du courrier on revoit il ya du
rouge à lèvres sur sa tablette ça donne
des lettres de fans
on va certes il ya du du pastis sans
alcool ouais à l'élève est en cure c'est
pas qu'il avait voulu essayer le
pacifique et est en fait le problème
c'est que c'était tellement caricatural
qu on a hésité à continuer et après on
avait plusieurs problèmes
est ce qu'on leur demande l'autorisation
oui surtout pas ils vont organiser
ils vont faire un bon l'école de police
et leur image deuxièmement est-ce que
c'est légal très important reste les
choses abandonnés sur la voie publique
c'est légal comme ça c'est très
important de savoir ce que vous abonner
sur la voie publique n'est plus à vous
il a l'art et toulon
troisièmement il fallait des gens avec
des hôtels particuliers au début mais ce
qu'on va voir là le prochain c'est jack
nicholson et jack nicholson ça marche
parce que vous êtes sûr que c'est jack
nicholson l'immeuble on peut pas savoir
à guy acquis sur les péchés et à los
angeles c'est très simple parce que on
peut faire un circuit la star mars à des
circuits organisés pour les touristes
donc vous à l'adresse des des célébrités
donc et puis avec le courrier on voit
tout et là tout le courrier 80 % du
courrier c'est des fans de la gente
féminine et les femmes qui lui écrivent
qu'ils les clauses de rendez vous et
c'est délirant mais il est quand même on
avait d'autres idées comme voisin de
polanski d'ailleurs dans la maison de
nicole polanski c'est le problème plus
aigu du devoir avant de dire que si tu
vas au 12 900 mulholland drive
tu as le 12 900 12 950 à charlène
madeleine et tu avais marlon brando mais
elle est alors là c'est intéressant
quand on regarde
ça d'abord c'est que alors est-ce que
vous avez censuré il ya absolument
jamais de médicaments
voilà ça n'a jamais rien de sexuel c'est
vrai la nicholson ou pour et ça c'est
vrai non il ya alors paradoxalement il
n'y avait pas grand chose mais c'est
vrai que pour ce qui concerne les
célébrités parce qu'on a fait d'autres
travaux derrière pour ce qui concerne
les célébrités
on s'est mis une une limite on s'est mis
une ligne rouge
jerry dyckmans juridiquement c'est
important pour eux parce que si jamais
on trouvait une seringue
on pourrait avoir une vision différente
parce que ça peut être pour leur chasse
devrait donc il ya une interface basée
sur un gottéron donc l'année les nominés
on a décidé d'écarter tout ce qu'ils
avaient une connotation médical ou
sexuelles le principe paradoxalement à
ce qu'on peut imaginer nous le principe
c'était vraiment de faire un portrait et
non pas de faire un scandale et
d'ailleurs toutes ces célébrités ne nous
en ont jamais voulu d'avoir fait leurs
poubelles et nicholson qui est venu il
ya c'était quand deux trois ans à
l'enterrement de willy rizzo qui était
son pote photographe de paris match m'a
dit la meilleure photo le meilleur
portrait qui me représente c'est ma
poubelle
on va voir celle de kate moss on va
constater qu'il n'ya rien d'illégal dans
la poubelle google de kate moss non un
peu d'alcool mais le geste alors il ya
des fleurs et c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce qu'en général il n'y a
aucun produit frais comme si tout l'été
célébrité ne consommer que des marques
pourquoi y at il jamais de produits
souhaités pour une autre pour une raison
différente
au début quand on l'a fait on n'arrivait
pas à conserver parce que la récolte
qu'on faisait à los angeles
arrêté sur sur un mois donc on vous
because he après on a trouvé le système
de les mettre sous vide et des congés
qui consommaient quand même des fruits
et des légumes
je suis plus de choses organique à
l'image et il faut imaginer que
lorsqu'on a commencé après la france à
los angeles sur inspiration de faut lui
rendre hommage de daniel filipacchi qui
était le patron de paris match et qui
avait trouvé le travail incroyable et
qui disait c'est incroyable ce que vous
avez fait c'est marcel duchamp c'est ce
prix c'est andy warhol enfin nous on
était juste moi c'est lui qui nous a
poussés à aller faire los angeles faut
imaginer qu'on ramène tout dans des
cantines en faire je te dis pas en
excédent de bagages c'est le pib de la
somalie et imagine la trt
du douanier à roissy quand il ouvrait
nos cantines et qui voyait des tonnes de
poubelles à mais qu'il devenait dingue
de voir la poubelle de madonna qui hélas
beaucoup beaucoup d'eau alors oui bon
c'est pas c'est peut-être ses enfants
oui je sais comment mener tu sais pas
les domestiques madonna elle faisait sa
soupe à la nominer râle la preuve oui il
a des bonnes à gérer même des rumeurs il
y avait même des rumeurs à une époque
qui disait qu'elle prenait des bains
d'eau minérale c'est juste commencer si
c'est pas les doubistes hic
ah non parce que les états à los angeles
les domestiques c'est souvent des
mexicains des sud américains et alors si
vous voulez devant les maisons à l'heure
du déjeuner il ya les trucks qui passe
avec la nourriture pour eux d'ados qui
mangent pas ils mangent pas de culture
latino voilà latine aux îles où tu vas
me wehrli wirth à toute l'ailé les rues
et entre chaque jardin backyard enfin à
l'arrière des maisons tu as une petite
rue de service qui sert aux livraisons
et qui sert justement à ce que le
personnel vient viennent déjeuner sans
manger la même chose que à tout à gauche
en dessous du jus de fruits il y as on
dirait qu'elle a une broyeuse
ah bah non mais ça c'est les choix et
les broyeurs aux etats unis c'est très
très répandue est en fête puisse pas
dire ce qu'elle a alors réussi à ce qui
a fait vraiment déclenché que une
parution haut de gamme c'est-à-dire
vanity fair aux états unis la couverture
du sunday times magazine
ça a été publiée dans le monde entier
sait que le jour où on fait la poubelle
de ronald reagan qui était président des
états unis on va la voir aussi un
sénateur de californie et qui avait un
goût affirmé fernand des sénateurs le
californien égale à celle de c'est un
problème parce que lui n'a pas de projet
trois heures et il venait de temps en
temps et nous on a attendu un week-end
qui viennent et huard je me lève
désolé pour les caméras mais chez
obligée de me lever et tu as on voit on
voit pas c'est très flou tu as quand
même du papier en tête nue tête stade-ci
quoi de service des fat
à l'époque c'étaient des facs donc c'est
aussi intéressant d'imaginer l'évolution
c'est tout ce courrier aujourd'hui
n'existerait plus parce qu'aujourd'hui
tous courriers ont le recevrai phare par
mail sur les écrans donc c'est aussi
intéressant sociologiquement et tu as le
nom des gardes du corps des cdd qu'est
ce que c'est que ce soutien gorge
la loire pierre de nancy reagan elle a
le droit d'avoir un vampire comme tout
le monde j'ai pas tes vieux tu es vieux
tout ravager l'asie mais je le ferai
dorénavant plus ça se fait dans les
meilleurs cas chaque fois on a un esprit
archéologiques parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on fouille trois mois on est même
nous mêmes surpris on retrouve michael
jackson par exemple on a l'impression
qu'ils lui jette beaucoup moins de
choses que les autres
vaslui consomme très peu bah oui ça
m'étonne quand même qu'ils consomment
six points en tête qu'il était
uniquement de passage sur deux trois
gros parce que s'il y en a des airs de
brigitte bardot qu'on a ratés alors
brigitte bardot par exemple la
connaissent bien est ce que vous avez
appris des choses bat pas grand chose
c'est significatif
elle est menée à les animaux et un
couperet pour un peu d'autorité au pôle
isa voilà aujourd'hui encore rêver la
ddt bouffer chez elle et d'ailleurs elle
va très très bien
ben c'est le mec du parisien il j'ai
gueulé kiffar pendant un grand sujet sur
elle et il m'a dit j'étais bouffer chez
elle elle m'a servi cette pizza la folie
la poubelle de mick jagger
alors il faut savoir que vu le succès
absolument époustouflant que vous avez
rencontrées avec cette idée qu'il faut
dire étape sedan génial et dont le rendu
est très graphique très très beaux
appartements aulas vous êtes parti vous
avez découvert vous étiez des rues de
log géant pmu tout à l'heure la
mythologie c'est l'étude des déchets ça
vient du grec rudeau ceux du latin rue
du ce les décombres les déchets gallas
et part donc c'est pourquoi pour
pourquoi on étudie les poubelles à
l'université jusqu'à imaginer que ça
génère des emplois dans des toutes
petites sociétés genre suez
environnement véolia faut savoir un truc
important on est en plein dedans de
grève de poubelles en fermant on est
vraiment dans l'actualité mais il faut
quand même savoir que la terre produit
chaque année 4000 milliards de tonnes de
déchets 4000 milliards de tonnes dont
seulement un quart est valorisée et
recycler c'est plus que ça 9 milliards 9
milliards de toute façon quand on est au
milliard et 2 150 et 250 millions
deux classes tic qui peuvent passer à
partir de l'oeuvre moi c'est ça qui m'a
frappé aussi vous avez fait les
poubelles de de millionnaires là sont
tous des millionnaires ça c'est marrant
mick jagger parce qu'on le voit pas trop
sur la photo mais en fait ici là des
toutes petites bouteilles d'evian c'est
ce qui fait il boit une gorgée il a
refermé la gêne à dire que toutes ces
bouteilles sont à moitié plein ou à
moitié vide enfin bon et et lui et lui
quand il broie saint-louis bailleur il
profite d'un roi il revoit et revoir ses
pas on peut pas les reconstituer cd
comme des données c'est les confettis
ouais
qu'il est beau et ça va me changer ça a
bien changé l'époque des rolling stones
aujourd'hui mais que jeger regarde 1 2 3
4 5
ces cinq produits c'est pour fabriquer
son point le mec il et vegan bio écolo
maintenant il est totalement
alors quand je n'étais que finit pas
suivi pas les bouteilles d'eau ouais
ouais on est tous plein de paradoxes
mais tu sais pourquoi mais bien pourquoi
ne faiblit pas parce que quand on voit
la bouteille après on postillonne dans
sa bouteille et l'exil tourner tu veux
dire qu'on à son adn a non seulement des
choses avec des bactéries
donc vous avez beaucoup de millionnaires
là aussi vous avez fait les poubelles de
deux milliardaires français très célèbre
françois pinault et baba amro puis vous
êtes attaqués aux familles anonyme
celle qu'on a vu tout à l'heure on va
les revoir la famille aisée de
10 et les familles défavorisées on va
dire d'ivry qui fait suite et qu'est ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'il consomme tous
la même chose
la même heure soit pineau mick jagger la
famille frédéric tassy tout prix mais
nous tous j'imagine coffret nos
poubelles
il ya certains produits qui sont des
produits phare où on nourrit confusément
et je suis sûr que c'est dans le monde
entier bien sûr alors il ya trouvé une
petite différence c'est ça qui a été
assez amusant c'est que nous on a vu
dans dans les expositions qu'on a fait à
travers le monde les gens nous
connaissent pas donc on espionne un peu
on provoque même en dix ans franchement
c'est des poubelles c'est de la merde
enfin ils essayent de provoquer un peu
les gens qui viennent visiter ce genre
d'exposition est en fait il ya trois
lectures cirque il ya un côté très c'est
vrai qu'on dessus ming hard campbell
soup can ce de warhol en fait y'a un
côté assez esthétique
après il ya un reflet sur ta propre
consommation
parce que tu t'appelles frederico mick
jagger c'est la même produit pour tout
le monde et après il ya le côté conte à
tous où les gens passent une demi-heure
à regarder les petits détails et le côté
voyeur qu'on a tous évidemment
donc c'est un groupe que j'avais vécu
donc yaya par exemple celles qui ont 30
ans le packaging notamment aux états
unis ali habouha jean a beaucoup diminué
à cause de l'eau décidé l'obésité g star
mais ça a beaucoup diminué ça changeait
quand même un tout petit peu vers c'est
marrant parce que le mec de le numéro 2
de coca cola monde
il était venu nous voir d'atlanta et ils
disaient ah ça c'est un français le mec
il était venu nous voir ils voulaient
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient faire avec
nous mais on a dit on peut pas parce que
imagine si on trouvera il veut pas nous
sponsoriser mais voulait faire quelque
chose et nous on lui a dit on peut pas
parce qu'ils imaginent qu'on trouve pas
de coca wii ou si tu nous sponsorisent
comme on en trouve partout les gens
voire plus mais il voulait qu'on retire
certaines marques pour sa marque phare
complètement car c'est le travail est
alors plus rien à voir il y en a qui en
revanche ne consomme pas comme les
autres on va le voir parce qu'ils lui
qui font d'ailleurs la fiche de
l'exposition autopsie c'est le malawi
c'est le malawi le pays les plus pauvres
du monde ça c'est une famille où malawi
ouais ça c'est une famille alors y'a que
des végétaux que de minéraux et alors ce
qui est incroyable c'est que le malawi
est un des pays que j'ai visité
plusieurs fois qui est un des pays les
plus propres au monde pourquoi parce
qu'il n'ya pas de plastique
il n'y a pas de port hope non il n'y a
pas de poubelles et donc c'est super
c'est un
q perte ou s'ils récupéreront le foie
gras ou 3g donc les recycle et elle est
unique et c'est assez beau et il ya une
collectionneuse à washington qui a ça
c'est super crâneur mais on est obligés
de le dire qui a dans son salon afdn à
helmut newton et cette photo entre les
deux ce que les très graphique c'est
dans les mêmes tons ces 300 mètres et on
retrouve évidemment la bouteille de coca
cola en eau en verre est incroyable si
on avait voulu la faire comme ça donc
c'est comme moi je suis tombé sur la
tête j'ai dit ah vous ne va pas trop la
masse et les données sont exactement
j'ai dit à bruno on va pas la mettre ces
les dieux sur 2010 mais on l'a trouvé
les dieux sont tombés sur la tête jeudi
pour les plus jeunes c'est un film wim
été tournée en afrique du sud dans le
même uche
ouais il y avait un je sais plus quand
on s'appelait les bouches ban mais de
petite taille un jour j'avais une
bouteille de coca jeté d'un avion ils
partaient à la découverte de la grande
ville mahboula soumahoro non pas un
commentaire sur les dieux sont tombés
sur la tête mais sur toute cette sur
toute cette exposition alors c'est
intéressant j'aime beaucoup le travail
esthétique enfin comment vous avez
agences et voilà comment vous avez
agences et les produits et après c'est
vrai que ça à saku sa touche à notre
notre côté voyeur un peu on a envie de
se dire mais alors qu'est-ce qu'ils font
qu est-ce qui voit là et alors qu'il ya
des grands points communs mais notamment
cette mondialisation avec le coq art
qu'on trouve chez les pays riches et les
pays pauvres chez les populations riches
et les populations pauvres pas d'accord
parce que ils viennent regarder ce qu'il
ya plusieurs visions ils viennent
regarder de près il se dit ça les
rassure parce que si même les gens
célèbres et riches comme dit il on a des
natures commun ils mangent la même chose
qu'eux alors cela dit si vous l'avez
fait vous l'avez sûrement fait au japon
la revanche c'est complètement différent
quand on se balade dans un supermarché
au japon les marques ne sont pas les
mêmes produits
une autre forme de constater beaucoup de
documentation de nissan de renault au
japon mais c'est vrai qu'en supermarché
japonais céder tout autre univers assure
même 5 errants esthétiquement c'est
autre chose ça qui est intéressant
oui c'est beaucoup plus fournie aussi
désormais semaine un petit manteau mais
ce travail ce travail
qu'on fait sur les anonymes c'est super
intéressant parce que là on déconne on
raconte pas mal de trucs mais en fait il
se trouve que mon petit frère est
archéologue il est directeur de
recherche au cnrs et quand il a vu le
travail qu'on avait fait avec bruno sur
des célébrités il dit mais ce que tu
fais c'est mon taf c'est mon boulot et
d'ailleurs c'était jean paul ii bull le
plus gros tas oui la france qui avait
manifesté verglacée
quelle mémoire danaïdes et stéphane me
dit mais c'est c'est incroyable parce
que ce que tu fais c'est vraiment mon
boulot imagine qu'on est la poubelle de
jules césar ou de napoléon il dit si moi
j'ai si j'avais la photo de la poubelle
d'une famille maya ou un cas j'aurai le
prix nobel d'archéologie parce qu'il est
spécialisée sur les peuples amérindiens
et le cnrs parce qu'on leur donne toutes
les photos nous ont dit ce travail on va
le sortir dans un siècle de siècle en
siècle
ce sera super intéressant parce que ils
peuvent pas financer ce voyage qu'on
fait dans 50 pays dans le monde et ce
sera quelque chose qu'ils vont garder
qui restera peut-être certainement plus
que les poubelles des célébrités il faut
espérer
justement qu'en voyant cesser ces
poubelles ces photos vision amis avez du
plastique avant on espérait que ce
casque et j'ai dû à pied dans du papier
c'est recyclable mais au moins du
placement même et le pas grâce à varèse
le complètement le lait cru que ça
serait ça ce serait fabuleux
vous avez commencé il ya 30 ans oui en
quatre ans invite vous continuer et on
vient de faire les poubelles de dieu là
non je te jeu à vis de dieu dieu oui je
ne savais pas comment faire donc on a
dit on va vers prix s'est cachée non
mais ont du coup on s'est dit on va
aller voir son envoyé on a envahi les
voies que celles gandolfo la résidence
d'été des papes est en fait qu'à celles
vendues le foot a plein de cure et plein
de bonnes soeurs donc tout est mélangé
on n'a pas pu isoler celle du pape
donc on a fait un curé un iman et un
rabbin on a fait les trois représentants
de dieu sur terre et bien une fois de
plus c'est horrible les trois boivent
cette de marques de boissons
gazeuses américaine et on apprend quand
même parce que tu apprends toujours
quelque chose quand 73 le grand rabbin
de new york a été invité à atlanta par
cette firme pas pour la recette pour les
ingrédients voici les cacher ou pas
cacher donc dieu s'appelle cccc enfin ça
veut dire que ça nous
n à des réflexions et des gens nous
apportent aussi des isbas tiens ça
c'était comme ça c'est comme ça à chaque
fois une espèce de recherches continuent
et on fait une pause je rappelle que
l'exposition autopsie c'est dansant
galerie yellowkorner à travers le monde
et à la galerie la une à saint germain
des prés on se retrouve dans un instant
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique ça
va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avait quand
même beaucoup plus à perdre que les
états unis je suis pas convaincu tout de
même que le jeu ne soit pas nous
équilibré qu'il n'y paraît vous avez un
certain nombre de secteurs d'activité
aux états unis qui ont été lourdement
impactés s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont en
train de perdre leur statut de
superpuissance et unique superpuissance
en la chine est un pays qui peut
beaucoup plus rapidement que n'importe
quel autre pays du monde se passer des
états unis et entraîné avec elle en plus
incertain d'autres pays européens clés
c'est aujourd'hui la chine qui remet en
cause l'hégémonie américaine
[Musique]
là
mais
[Musique]
non
et l'actualité c'est évidemment le
corona virus là aussi c'est un peu un
effet de la mondialisation
mon ami quand même plus d'un mois avant
que l'information remonte de ou ham
jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers cas
du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre dans les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
se faire sortir notamment en france à
cause des touristes non mais il ya eu
quand même des mesures très autoritaire
de prise bien sûr mais pour pouvoir
stopper la contagion
il n'y a que des mesures autoritaires
qui peuvent être prises est ce qu'à un
message là en direction de trump c'est
constant chez les chinois depuis
toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau vous ai mis deux
cents ans à le faire alors venez pas
nous donner des leçons alors là à skis a
pas là aussi une autre leçon c'est que
la mondialisation dont on a dit que
pick-up ordre on y va on n'est pas très
bien outillé c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand
une épidémie vient de chine
bah elles se répandent dans le monde
entier
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui bruno
mouron et pascal rostain pour
l'exposition autopsie féloche pour son
nouvel album avec le mandoline orchestra
et mahboula soumahoro qui est docteur en
civilisation du monde anglophone
j'enseignais à l'université tour et vous
publié aux éditions de la découverte le
triangle et l'hexagone sous titré
réflexion sur une identité noire c'est
de la vôtre qu'il s'agit bien vous n'en
faites pas une généralité exactement
encore fallait il le préciser pourquoi
ce titre
le triangle et l'hexagone ce titre et
peut-être un rappel on parle souvent de
la france comme la france hexagonale et
ce qui à mon avis modèle un peu notre
vision et notre compréhension de de la
france et moi je vous dis un peu parlé
de cette vision française qui peut être
élargie et qui s'inscrit entre autres
mais qui s'inscrit dans la zone qu'on
appelle la zone atlantique et la zone
atlantique
c'est des amériques c'est l'europe et
c'est le continent africain et je pense
que quand on commence à réfléchir à tout
cela
peut-être que ça peut nous éclairer sur
des thématiques qui aujourd'hui semble
fâché et puis surtout sur la présence de
certaines populations au sein de
l'hexagone français est votre histoire
dit vous s'inscrit dans une histoire et
des géographies donc plus vaste que
votre parcours personnel
mais on pourrait dire de nous tous et
nous aime si bien que le fait que vous
soyez noir et moi nous nous change rien
à la fin on parle
de diaspora africaine et même de
diaspora noire ce qui moi m'a toujours
choqué la diaspora africaine je vous
comprends donc que c'est la référence à
la diaspora juive donc gaspor africaine
s'est tous les africains qui ne vivent
pas en afrique exactement qui vivent à
travers le monde mais parler de diaspora
noire ça m'a toujours choqué j'ai tord
les mains sales je ne veux pas qu'on
emploie le terme noir et aucun problème
et non non je sais pas c'est noir je dis
pas qu'elle est black c'est pas mais
revanche diaspora noire je trouve ça
bizarre mais en fait c'est un débat
scientifique
il ya des personnes qui utilisent des
chercheurs la diaspora noire diaspora
africaine et c'est une question de
positionnement
quand on parle de la diaspora africaine
on va parler de toutes les personnes
d'origine africaine proches ou
lointaines qui sont dispersés à travers
le monde et qui peuvent se réclamer de
l'afrique où qu'ils se définissent
eux-mêmes eux-mêmes pardon comme
africains quand on parle de la diaspora
noire en fait on parle de ce moment de
l'histoire où ceux qui ne se sont
d'ailleurs jamais défini comme africains
qui ont quitté l'afrique dans le
contexte de la traite négrière
transatlantique qui ont quitté l'afrique
en tant que yoruba en tant que bambara
en tant que giula et qui sont devenus
noirs donc noir c'est une catégorie plus
récentes dans l'histoire est tôt pour
dire que la diaspora africaine monde en
fait tous partie on est tous nous en
sommes exactement sortie d'afrique
exactement autres ça c'est dans le
meilleur des mondes puisque là quand on
parle de la diaspora
cette diaspora africaine où le mouvement
humain en dehors du continent africain
c'était un moment où personne ne se
définit défini scénique homme noir ni
comme blanc donc on peut le regretter
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
moment de l'histoire très précis vous
est le fruit
cette diaspora africaine est le fruit de
l'esclavagé et du colonialisme
en tout cas pour pour ceux qui sont là
depuis sa fin aujourd'hui il ya une
diaspora africaine aussi qui est là
parce qu'elle fait des affaires en
europe
exactement voilà bien entendu il ya est
attaché à cette diaspora une idée
d'infériorité qui vient justement du
fait que l aider à la fois de
l'esclavagé et du colonialisme
oui c'est l'invention de la catégorie
noir qui est une catégorie qui a été
créé en même temps que la catégorie
blanche
et dans cet ordre des choses dans cette
hiérarchie la catégorie blanche est
supérieure à la katibate l'esclavagisme
c'est elle qui colonialisent et c'est
elle qui colorise et qu'elle qui corrige
aussi puisque c'est vrai que ce sont les
blancs qui théorisent et les les races
vous rappeler que l' esclavage n'a pas
été inventé avec la traite négrière il l
a toujours existé oui mais que ce serait
avec la traite négrière négrière que
pour la première fois on aurait théorisé
l' esclavage à partir de la couleur de
la peau à partir de la couleur avant
mais je l'avais gizeh tout le monde
voilà voilà ça pour aller inscrire
ménager des personnes qui avait été
défaite lors de conflits ce voilà mais
c'était ce n'était pas ancrée dans le
corps autre chose que vous rappeler qui
est très important c'est que la
résistance ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
d'emblée c'est vrai c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut rappeler
certains prétendent que tout à coup ce
serait comme si et noir toutacoo
découvrait qu'il y avait des problèmes
raciaux n'ont toujours de l'argent parce
que c'est une évidence qu'ils font quand
même
marthe marteler on parle d'êtres humains
même si on parle d'êtres humains qui ont
été racialisée c'est-à-dire placés dans
des catégories et parfois si les gens me
disent les déshumaniser également mais
évidemment chaque être humain chaque
être humain face à la domination va
développer des stratégies de résistance
pour quand on parle de la traite
négrière par exemple l'une des
stratégies les plus les plus anciennes
c'était tout simplement de s'échapper
lors qu'on lorsqu'ont été kidnappé à
l'intérieur des terres pour être ramenés
vers les côtes où étaient les bateaux
négriers ça pouvait être abordé travaux
des bateaux négriers par dont le suicide
par exemple c'était toutes les
tentatives de révolte enfin ces
attitudes innombrables nombreux journaux
aux états unis riez vous ce qu'est la
reine jinga we ll c'est la diplomatie
bien sûr ce qu'au xixème siècle est là
elle est le parcours d'ailleurs fait
sinon exactement et le est comment dire
le l'arrivée des européens c'est ce
qu'on oublie aujourd'hui c'est que quand
les européens sont arrivés en afrique
ils ont reconnu les instances politiques
qui existeraient ils sont ils ont fini
par s'imposer
ils ont fini par gagner la guerre
technologique mais en tout cas les
premières arrivées se sont caractérisées
par la diplomatie la plus belle dès lors
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs on dit que les noirs
africains ont été eux mêmes complices
des retraites parce que c'était eux qui
à les capturer
il ya les livres et aux aigris et voilà
il ya plusieurs années on n'osait pas
toujours s'aventurer sur ce continent
exactement donc il ya eu une complicité
certaine pour ceux qui voulaient
défendre leurs intérêts puisque
aujourd'hui on a cette image assez
simpliste de l'afrique et des africains
où tout le monde est et a mimé l'afrique
c'était comme l'europe a lui énormément
de santé oms le colonisé les animaux
c'était il y avait et il y avait de
l'esclavagisme entre pays africains
oui elle est bien sûr qu'ils ne se
définissait pas comme africains et s
étaient des ennemis donc on pouvait
réduire en esclavage
mi mai par contre ce qui est indéniable
c'est la pression que la mise en place
et le renforcement de la traite à placer
sur les groupes ou les entités
politiques qui ne voulaient pas
participer à la traiter soi c'est vous
ou soit vous soit vous nous aidez vous
soit sa population vous avez
fait une grosse grande partie de vous
êtes une supérieure aux états unis vous
avez également enseigné d'ailleurs je
crois qu est ce que ça quelle influence
a eu peu sur vous alors moi c'est ça a
été vraiment un éveil intellectuel aux
états unis j'ai eu accès à des champs de
recherche auquel tu n'avais jamais été
exposées en france est souvent dit si on
me dit que c'est l' influence américaine
mais il ne faut pas oublier qu'aux états
unis il ya énormément de personnes
issues du monde entier qui enseigne donc
des personnes comme edouard glissant ou
maryse condé ce sont des français qui
était en poste aux etats-unis quand j
étais donc cette ce champ de la diaspora
cette idée d'une d'une identité noire
transnationales global
c'est vraiment là bas que j'ai pu
l'explorer c'est des choses qu'on a du
mal à un accident à la base c'est que la
question raciale et centrale oui elle
est la ségrégation a existé aux états
unis et alors qu'elle n'a pas existé en
france si joséphine baker arrive en
france aient envie de rester si jack
johnson le champion du monde le premier
championnat du monde noir de boxe qui a
déclenché des émeutes l'info qui bat un
blanc ont laissé des émeutes quand il
arrive en france
il est ébloui qu'on le traite comme un
homme normal il faudrait 6 créole est
désolé tous les grand jazzman miles
davis d'actes mans là qui arrivent ici
peuvent s'asseoir dans n'importe quel
bar ils peuvent coucher avec des femmes
blanches et ça ne pose aucun problème
etc etc le clown chocolat dont on parle
qui est une superstar en 1900 en france
à des petites amies blanche c'est une
superstar il est des petites amies
blanche ça ne pose aucun problème
on sait bien que c'est très différent en
français vous y faites allusion
d'ailleurs c'est devant la constitution
en france mais on pourrait dire dans
l'est dans la culture française
on ne regarde pas la couleur aujourd'hui
c'est en fait c'est différent c'est
juste lacombe sa pointe vers la
complexité de cette question raciale
quand le tous les exemples que vous avez
comment dire cités sont des exemples de
personnes noires qui viennent des
amériques
et là il ya l'association entre
l'identité raciale et la nationalité
donc s'il ya joséphine baker par exemple
qui est une superstar en france à un
moment où il
absolument impossible pour elle d'être
une superstar aux états unis mais elle
peut être reçue il ya eu des super stars
aux états unis noir qui n'avait pas le
droit de rentrer dans le bar où ils
avaient le droit de jouer c'est vrai
donc d'accord et y compris à new york on
croit que c'est dans l'axé dans le sud
aussi toujours le cas de jesse owens que
le hitler aurait refusé de à qui on a
refusé de serrer la main j'ai un pic de
36 g d'héroïne samedi c'est faux il m'a
fait un petit signe de la main de celui
qui a refusé de me recevoir c'est bon je
vais lui a refusé de le rencontrer
donc avec ce voyage commentaires à
travers l'atlantique c'est comme si ces
noirs des amériques
devenez des noirs ni désirable des noirs
qui sont civilisés et qu'on doit opposer
comprendre aux noirs d'afrique ou au
noir des territoires qu'on appelle
d'outre-mer en france et c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas l'équivalent d'une
joséphine baker et c'est pour ça que
tous les toutes les stars que vous avez
mentionnés sont des stars étrangères moi
ce qui m'intéressait c'était de savoir
des personnes qui étaient noirs et qui
étaient issus de l' empire colonial
français à l'époque
que pouvait-elle devenir esclave et le
même degré janvier elle pouvait devenir
député il y avait des députés doit y
compris africains et antillais l
assemblée nationale en france au début
du 20e siècle
il ya eu un ministre noir dans le
cabinet de clemenceau pour la première
grille anciens il était chargé cela dit
d'aller recruter des soldats noirs pour
faire la guerre il dit mais il était
ministre maintenant il les garde
républicaine se mettait au garde à vous
devant ses hommes l'auraient bien servi
j'ai enfin tu vois les intérêts
représentent bien exact mais il y avait
quand même c'est une sorte de fossé une
dichotomie entre cette france hexagonale
est cette france qu'on appelait des
outre mer oui c'est à dire que quand
vous parlez de la non existence de la
ségrégation où on pourrait même dire la
non existence de l' esclavage c'est
parce que l'esclavagé a eu lieu dans ces
territoires a été abolie dans l'hexagone
j'avais raison des le moyenne exactement
voilà donc c'est ça c'est ça la
différence avec les états unis la
population noire indigènes celle qui est
du pays
elle ait toujours été sur place donc il
a fallu légiférer pour pouvoir la gérer
bout la ségrégation continuez sur votre
identité noire bull à soumahoro vous
raconter qu enfant vous viviez dans une
cité hlm en banlieue avec
des familles émigrées à peu près qui
venait d'à peu près tous les endroits du
monde dans europe les italiens les
espagnols du maghreb bien entendu
d'afrique que c'était des familles dh
désargenté évidemment banlieue populaire
mais qui avait le haut font le même vécu
oui et jusqu'à un certain point mais
lundi alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ce jusqu'à un certain point en quoi vous
en tant que jeune fille adolescente
noire à l'époque n'aviez pas le même
vécu que la famille d'à côté arabe
française parce qu'il y avait des
français blancs qui vivaient là où le
mal vécu c'est le vécu social venant
dans ces enceintes sont dans ces
endroits de près de vitry sur seine
derrière le kremlin bicêtre on est
vraiment il ya une communauté sociale et
ensuite il ya la question tabou en
france elle donc qu on ne peut pas
aborder
c'est la question raciale la question
raciale ça veut dire que par exemple si
je parle d'une famille antillaise
les antillais sont citoyens français
depuis 1848 si moi je suis d'origine
ivoirienne la côte d'ivoire avec son
indépendance en 1960 enfin voilà vous
connaissez les développements politiques
et donc dans la rue une fois qu'on se
sent s'intéresse au corps et à sa
signification
quelle pourrait être la différence entre
une antillaise et moi même elle est
passée par l adhésion s'être écurité
esclaves et pas vous wi lan mais est-ce
qu'on saurait que l'antillaise et
française est ce qu'on va dire à cette
épreuve à cette antillaise
tu viens d'où et si on nous dit tu viens
d'où sachant qu'elle est française
depuis 1804 fille 48 de quoi parle-t-on
et c'est ça dont je parle c'est surtout
diom qui était décrit eu des clients que
j'aime beaucoup d'origine s'est dit d'y
aller vous raconter dans un de ses
livres que quand elle est dans le train
avec des américains des australiens et
cetera on les regarde
ils ont tout à fait bonnes raisons
d'être là ils sont blancs et qu' elle
qui pourtant français est exact est la
seule française du groupe qu'un soldat
salle du groupe
on a un besoin d'arguments du doigt elle
vient exactement et c'est de ça dont je
veux parler c'est ça qui est peut-être
parfois inaudible ou difficile à faire
comprendre il ya comme une conversation
secrète qui se passe sur la base des
corps moi je veux bien je parle pas du
tout de décence de biologie
mais en tout cas on a une apparence du
corps qui a été filmé à versailles il me
dit que juste panon l'universalisme je
le dis je l'assument
il n'existe pas il est situé et il a été
définie compris comme blanc comme on
pourrait dire comme qu'il a été compris
comme masculin aussi c'est d'autres
questions vous vous vous et vous ajoutez
également que votre identité noire vous
placent dans une position en fait de
personnes dominée dans un pays dominants
exactement là ça peut peut-être faire
écho à ce qu'on disait de là comment
dire de la petite bouteille de coca cola
qui qui apparaît même jusqu au malawi
cessé de traits communs de cette
mondialisation quand on est noir en
france on fait partie des options des
citoyens français on appartient à une
nation riche une nation importante qui a
un poids militaire enfin voilà qui fait
la pallice en afrique et qui fait la
police en afrique et ailleurs et à
l'intérieur de ce pays fort de ce pays
dominants on peut être placé comment
dire occuper la place d'une minorité qui
est dominé de manière multiples sauf qu
on a aussi des attaches et des
appartenances ailleurs donc moi si je
suis une noire française
je peux me plaindre je peux dénoncer
certaines choses mais je suis quand même
mieux traités on va dire
internationalement que quelqu'un qui
aurait strictement un passeport ivoirien
et donc quel est mon rapport à ces
personnes qui peuvent être même de ma
famille c'est à dire que pour certains
africains ou pour certains ivoiriens je
peux passer pour blanche
je suis une française j'ai de l'euro je
peux voyager le monde entier presque
sans demander de visa
je fais pas la queue à la préfecture
pendant des heures pour aller renouveler
ma carte ma carte monde mon titre de
séjour c'est ça les ambiguïtés quand on
parle de race en vérité même si on
essaie de mettre de côté cette question
de manière assez assez ridicule est
assez simpliste en france
en vérité on parle de choses très très
complexes vous parlez des diables
véritablement un conflit de loyauté à la
fois parce que vous décrivez vous êtes à
la fois
citoyenne des pays dominants oui mais
aussi à l'intérieur de cette minorité
noire en france vous êtes surdiplômés
par exemple donc là aussi il ya hexagone
y avoir un conflit de loyauté vous
faites partie des dominants en termes de
diplômes plus éduqués de la nation exact
est néanmoins vous êtes noir
oui parce que c'est quand je marche dans
la rue on ne sait qu'on ne connaît pas
mon diplôme et ça fait assez incertain
et ça s'est défait du corps après
évidemment que je peux essayer de
biaiser et évidemment il ya un doctorat
évidemment il ya un enseignement à
l'université mais ça c'est quand on
parle quand on nous voit qu est ce qu on
voit exactement
vous avez dit redevenu invite si je peux
finir par dodge était venu à l'une de
vos émissions il ya quelques années et
donc on m'avait dit de me diriger vers
la loge et les agents de sécurité
m'avait demandé à plusieurs reprises si
j'étais vraiment invité si j'étais
vraiment invitée à estoril avec beaucoup
de noirs qu'est-ce que je suis invité
dans le public où est ce que je suis
vraiment invité invité gênant je suis
vraiment invitée pour aller dans la loge
donc ce moment là et ça ne change rien
que l'agent de sécurité soit noir ou
arabe par exemple c'est là que ça
devient des questions de représentation
qui nous a fait nous tous
et j'imagine sans arêtes dans une
existence ces petites choses là où ses
sens inverse sans arrêt c'est quotidien
c est encore la plus chargée est un
homme ou en plus y'a les contrôles
policiers puisqu'il n'y a pas les mêmes
contrôles policiers sur les femmes ou
les personnes qui paraissent comme des
femmes si vous êtes une femme qui paraît
comme un homme et que vous êtes mort il
vous arrivera la maison qu'en fait vous
et c'est pratiquement la conclusion de
votre livre vous avez décidé d'être
voilà c'est vrai oui j'avais décidé
d'être noah c'est à dire que vous
décidez de le revendiquer de le
revendiquer de l'assumer de ne pas
essayer de me transformer de ne pas
essayer de devenir blanche ce qui serait
impossible déjà fini en méme envoûtant
socialement et en plus de me retourner
vers cette histoire est de me retourner
vers sait faire c'est vers ces
occurrences pardon qui est et de l'est
oui teulet donc d'en être fier puisque
noir comme aux catégories ça a été
fabriqué comme une catégorie inférieure
et moi je refuse cette infériorité et je
ne veux pas du tout me lancer me plonger
dans l'aveuglément à la race est pas tu
es noir mais je ne le sais pas enfin et
je ne vois pas ce qui est tout à fait
faux pour commencer mais c est ce que
même en me voyant de manière différente
est-ce que je peux être traités de
manière équitable c'est en même temps ce
qui vous met dans la position de nous
regarder comme blanc oui et à partir de
ce moment là on commence à vous faire
des procès il ya indigénisation il ya
des colonialismes vieillard assis un
communautarisme et yara voilà donc on
prétend dommage de ne m'avoir jamais vue
ni traités comme les noirs moi je dis
juste que ces catégories s'explique
historiquement il ya des noirs il ya des
blancs est ce qu'on peut se parler faire
tomber les masques et se parler
honnêtement pour pouvoir dépasser ces
catégories au lieu de placer enfin de
mettre la poussière sous le tapis et
dire il ne se passe rien alors qu'on a
des explosions vraiment régulière donc
le dire que quelqu'un est blanc comme
dire que quelqu'un est noir ça peut
aussi ça pourrait être ne pas un sur ne
pas être insultant o le livre s'intitule
le triangle et l'hexagone il est signé
mahboula soumahoro ils viennent paraître
aux éditions la découverte
[Musique]
féloche vous vous sortez un nouvel album
avec le mandoline orchestra cette fois
un album dans lequel vous reprenez
chicplanète de la sphère louis triaud
qui était veulent sans doute votre
groupe préféré avant les années 80 on va
regarder tout de suite le clip
chicplanète interprété par féloche avec
le mans doline orchestra
[Musique]
chine
dessus
[Musique]
et
et en tournée
un ami terriens à nigérienne regardez la
planète sous nos yeux
elle me convient car c'est la mienne
que j'y suis bien et qu'on est tous deux
ont été censurés oui c'est dire que les
algorithmes font repérer très vite qu'il
ya 2 minutes 20 il y avait 17 ans au
xxème siècle il y avait des side et et
puis en plus moi je c'était vraiment ça
partait deux mois d'un truc
bon il ya la chanson chic planète et
puis on était ensemble comme ça on se
dit c'est marrant un peu de de chez pas
de liberté qu'est ce que vous voulez sur
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui les
choses c'était compliqué toujours est il
que cette chanson de 1987 et dont on
voit à quel point les choses ont changé
aujourd'hui on dirait plutôt pauvre
planète
on est bien trop de fûts c'est plutôt
seul mot d'ordre
vous avez l'impression et puis en plus
sur tout ce bleu on peut remarquer mais
c'est vrai on mandoline isner dans mon
orchestre il ya des professeurs de
mandoline dans les conservatoires et
vraiment je peux vous dire que les
petits gamins n'ont pas du tout les
petits gars mans en fait le chef
d'orchestre est simple florentino calvo
c'est vraiment un mec incroyable
d'encelade l'élite pour tous est lui
l'un saigne la mandoline argenté du
conservatoire mais c'est tout nouveau il
faut quinze ans mais ça ou vingt ans
même c'est la mandoline ça a été
l'instrument de prédilection des
chanteur napolitain est vrai ça a été ou
17 18e 19e siècle c'est extrêmement
populaire mêmes auspices à décoder en
france par l'accordéon et et ailleurs
aux états unis notamment c'était très
populaire c'est démodé par le jazz il
préfère la guitare et à allaiter n'y
trouverez pas beaucoup de musiciens
noirs vérifier pour jouer de la
mandoline gic de blanc d'ailleurs
ducarne fruits et tout avec la mandoline
mais non ce que je voulais dire c'est
que argenteuil je voudrais revenir là
dessus parce que je trouve ça rebondit
je trouve ça génial d'un enseignement de
la mandoline
c'est des gamins en fait c'est on va au
conservatoire comme une classe de mme
angeline tous les gamins c'est tous les
gamins du monde entier pendant qu'ils
sont représentés dans la ville
d'argenteuil qui apprennent la mandoline
c'est quand même génial à voir ça marche
et que pour tous et on tend donc mais ce
qui est bon le suiveur prenait 2 dans
cet album la chanson de bourvil la
mandoline et dans lequel il dit j'ai
j'aurais pu plaire à tout le monde et
surtout plaire aux filles
malheureusement je joue de la mandoline
et jouer un petit rôle et en en 1958 à
l'époque où plus personne ne l'était
c'était la romantique par excellence ont
trait aux filles en jouant de la
mandoline
d'ailleurs quand on dit jouer de là il
est venu y mal jouer de la mandoline
ça veut dire que c'est mon baby by me
séduire c'est vrai que en plus il ya un
double sens dans cette chanson qui est
quand même incroyable petit instrument
pour visser c'est bon en ville c'est
superbe et c'est bon c'est vraiment
l'instrument romantique mais c'est vrai
que c'est plus personne enfin alors à
part depuis 15 ans à argenteuil
oui non plus pour mandoline on va dire
mon deuxième vous est venue l'idée qu
est ce que ça de particuliers l'amant de
moi j'ai toujours jouer de la mandoline
mais moi je joue et je fans de prins
depuis que je suis tout petit donc je
joue de la mandoline funk là on voit
hisser l'équipe c'est mes amis de
mandoline orchestra mais moi j'ai aussi
des années à jouer avec ma mandoline et
je ne la joue pas comme ça dire que ce
travail sur se disent que c'est vraiment
un travail d'écriture avec vincent bien
demandé il ya quelques c'est vraiment
des gens qui sont pointues en musique
classique
donc c'est la mandoline donc la
mandoline c'est à dire c'est comme un
orchestre symphonique sûr qu'on attire
vous êtes très très nombreux en tournée
est là vous serez aux trois baudets on
est le 15 assure choix dans argenteuil
il ya les gentils nahd donc on est 70
vraiment mais on tourne et on est 15
et c'est vrai que c'est comme un
orchestre normal c'est la mandoline donc
c'est comme le violon c'est même
tessiture la mandole comme l'alto le
mans de moncel le violoncelle et non
plus nous on a les guitares qu'ils font
c'est un peu la base brute mais qui nous
accompagnent quoi c'est pas eux les
stars et le sait ils font office de
senna un peu l'art et la contrebasse qui
dans certains orchestres comme à
marseille chez vincent clerc demandé un
peu ils ont des demandes aux basses quoi
c'est une contrebasse et à la il faisait
à sauver cet album vous fait des
reprises bien il ya du délit d'ail et du
lait aux fins et on a entendu chic
planète
mais il ya aussi vous certain nombre de
vos chansons parmi les plus célèbres
aussi que vous reprenez avec des
mandolines et et puis à des nouvelles
compositions exprès pour la mandoline
vous serez bientôt en tournée nantes le
5 mars pornichet le 6 et paris aux trois
baudets le 30 avril
vous serez 15 à autre mode et on sera
même plus mais je sais pas comment va se
faire ce que la scène est pas très
grande et ajoutent deux fois le crumble
et rambo dff est décédé des forces
alliées c'est ça que je trouvais super
dirais avec le recasement d'une parce
que moi lorrain depuis des années je
joue à électrique à fond donc c'est très
fort le volume et en plus j'ai fait j'ai
joué dans des groupes punks donc je sais
très bien que je veux du son et là j'ai
découvert la délicatesse la subtilité
avec des musiciens qui seront donc
j'apprends ça et aux trois baudets
on va pouvoir bien cent ans déjà c'est
pas trop grand parce qu'on a déjà joué
dans des gymnases avec lorca c'était
plus compliqué là on va s'entendre sur
scène et c'est c'est important si les
trois baudets parce qu'un hameau pascal
rostain si je peux me permettre vraiment
parce que c'était mon pote gainsbourg
ouais je retrouve un peu j'ai envie de
dire gainsbourg sort de ce corps parce
que j'ai un nom je connaissais pas aux
normes et la mandoline
non c'est pas ça je retrouve sa place
sur sa façon de parler de chanter dans
l'extrait qu'on a vu que je connaissais
pas et c'est trés c'est très
gainsbourien pour moi l'album féloche on
the moon the line orchestra sang le 14
février vous serez en concert aux trois
baudets à paris le 30 avril est en
tournée dans toute la france
le triangle et l'hexagone de maboule à
soumahoro c'est paru aux éditions de la
découverte et l'exposition autopsie de
bruno mouron et pascal rostain c'est
dansant galerie yellowkorner à travers
le monde et à la une
jusqu'au 15 avril merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui